hey matt and chris what's up it's grace
from michigan hi grace what up getting
your advice on a question for kind of
both my husband and i we have been
together since high school i'm now 23
he's 25. we've been married for two
years
and our parents are constantly asking us
we need to have kids
get some grandkids and
you know my husband i just like
vacationing we like having time for him
and i
we really enjoy this time that
we can have just the two of us and all
of our friends have kids so it's
constantly a thing to like you know
should we have kids that are around
their kids age
should we worry about that and um yeah
just want your opinion i know chris you
have a beautiful
baby boy and man i'm sure that you'd be
a great father one day if it's in your
future
and um yeah you know my husband and i
have been fans of you guys for a while
we've been ride or dies for chris
through everything support you through
everything i'm an er nurse so i've been
through
a lot and
my husband's a therapist so he we both
have pretty heavy jobs and we just
appreciate all the laughs that you guys
give us so just get back with that if
you're good with that and love to hear
your advice
thanks guys
sounds like you're wrong it goes so you
go first sweet heart
sweetheart and here's the deal
uh first of all we sh this is adorable
because she [ __ ] sent something in
the king and this thing in the wing and
we just covered it but
now i'm glad she's asked it on life
lifeline okay because i want to hear
what you have to say was this the
question she asked on that the same
question oh really i was like i know
this chick how do i know her
this is the main problem
people whether it be your mom or your
dad or whoever their friends dude it's
so annoying everybody wants you
to go to the next step yes dude let me
live [ __ ] yes let me live now
this is where honestly and i know you
don't like this but the spin move would
work in spades dude okay so give me when
are you having kids
i am one spin out and leave
dude she's also 23.
live in the moment dude every time you
do something it's not good enough
somebody comes up well when you're gonna
have kids yeah boom you have a kid
you're happy now oh when you're gonna
have another one yeah my brother or
sister yeah you're happy now you got two
kids oh
the question just you know what shoot
right to the question you really want to
ask when are you dying yeah right
yeah shoot
right to it dude yeah when someone asks
you hey when are you having a kid go
like this i'll probably leave it to be
95 and that's when i'll die right yeah
cause that's what you're really asking
cut to the chase let me live
[ __ ] yeah yeah i mean i
completely [ __ ] agree i think that
uh
it depends on your relationship with
with your parents but
just generally i think it should go
something like this
like ask me
say when are you go when matt what do
you think you're gonna have matt when do
you guys whenever the [ __ ]
i want so aggressive that's it though
that's shitty you know what that's why
they won't ask again right right that is
true because they're not gonna stop
asking they're gonna be sideways about
it they're gonna be this gonna be that
if you come down hard that one [ __ ]
time they won't do it again that is such
a [ __ ] stupid question for what is it
1824
it's not 200 [ __ ] years ago right
it's 20 22.
[ __ ] she's 23 years old yeah yeah
spin move mentality you know what you
could actually you pushed it back you
push it back yeah if you ask me again
never
that's the that's the best that is the
best [ __ ] answer if you ask me again
never and i want kids so if you ask me
again you ruined my life thanks a lot
that's a good one that's that's yeah
that's it
oh [ __ ] dude that's awesome that's
that's
that's the that's the answer and then if
they ask again go like this thanks for
ruining my life
[Music]
yeah i mean that's something [ __ ]
nelly out of the [ __ ] thing thanks
for watching
[Music]
you thought of that because it's hot as
[ __ ] in here it is hot um but you're the
one who keeps coming up wearing velour
don't don't
no but i i
i think though
that's so stupid to say i'm like
you could do that to your parents too
just don't don't but uh [ __ ] forgot i
was gonna [ __ ] oh also dude when she
started the video i made it sound like
she's like guilty about like enjoying
her life and wanting to travel [ __ ]
that dude wow you're gonna have whenever
you have kids from that point forward
you're never not gonna have kids enjoy
your life take as long as you want
you're 23 take 10 15 [ __ ] years if
you want to well the womb gets crusty
but okay no
10 15 20 [ __ ] years people having
babies in their late 40s now
[ __ ] your parents [ __ ] her parents well
deep deeper
don't forget the womb gets crusty okay
[ __ ] your parents
hello
[Music]